amérique du sud côte pacifique pérou
place se trouve une contrée formé de
désert de montagnes et de forêts trois
fois plus vaste que la france le pérou
est surtout connu pour la civilisation
qui avant la conquête espagnole ci était
épanoui
sous l'impulsion des emprunts cas des
vestiges monumentaux ont été laissées
par cet empire
aujourd'hui force le ratio ve chacun la
forteresse de machu picchu la plus
célèbre des ruines incas est
remarquable par l'important c'est la
beauté de ces constructions par son site
impressionnant où elles se dressent
les uns kahn ne connaissait pas d'autres
métaux que le cuivre regardez bien cette
pierre est avec le cuivre ils ont réussi
à tailler le granit plus dur est à
construire des bâtiments d'une réflexion
parfaite
et ses bâtiments repose sur une pierre
celle que vous venez de voir
la citadelle de machu picchu est
entourée de terrasses cultiver c'est un
genre quelques 900 m de dénivellation
aujourd'hui on distingue parfaitement
les vestiges de ces terrasses et cela
jusqu'au sommet du piton du coin n'a
picchu où l'on peut apercevoir leurs
bandes horizontales
mais le pérou n'est pas fait seulement
deux merveilles archéologiques la côte
est les premiers contreforts des andes
ne sont plus d'immenses déserts au
milieu desquels se dresse quelques
volcan calcinés
pourtant dans le creux des vallées les
hommes à force de labeur en domestiquer
la nature
grâce aux torts sommes descendus des
montagnes neigeuses de la cordillère le
sol a été irriguée est aujourd'hui les
oasis verdoyante
septembre au milieu des déserts de sable
jaune
le
c'est dans l'une de ces oasis que l'on
retrouve que l'on trouve plutôt une
réussite est construite à l'époque
coloniale avec ou pas aujourd'hui la
seconde ville du pays
ici rien ne paraît avoir changé le filet
conquistadors derrière les murs des
vieilles demeures se cachent les mêmes
patios fleuris qui abritèrent leur amour
de leur intrigue sanglante des églises
surchargés les sculptures témoignant de
leur ferveur religieuse sont aussi
blanche que si elle avait été achevé la
veille
au centre de cette cité enrichi par la
culture et l'industrie du poteau les
rues sont très émus malgré le métissage
la population est à peine différente de
celle que l'on rencontre à madrid ou à
seville mais dans les vieux quartiers on
trouve encore des duels tranquille une
flotte dans l'air un parfum premie
d'histoire pourtant toute cette richesse
n'aurait sans doute jamais dit stacey au
large des côtes du pérou ne s'adressait
pas les îles blanche
d'une désolation tous en bord sésime
vous allez le voir
voilà
elle semble n'être que de rock stérile
battu par le vent et la mer
mais des bandes immense d'oiseaux
sauvages viennent y déposer la richesse
le guano
l'engrais merveilleux qui a permis de
fertiliser les déserts de la côte en
effet le guano n'est rien d'autre que la
déjection des millions d'oiseaux qui
vivent sur ces îles c'est lui qui leur a
donné cette couleur blanche surprenante
et qui les fait ressembler à des
icebergs
les incas connaissait le guano et savait
l'exploiter mais la tradition s'est
perdu et lorsqu'au début du siècle
dernier ont repris l'exploitation du
bois non les il était tellement
recouverte il y en avait un peu plus de
40 mètres 40 mètres de déjections
d'oiseaux
aujourd'hui le guano et exploiter tous
les deux ans parce que la couche
d'engrais atteint 20 cm d'épaisseur ce
qui fut menteur raisonnable lui même
plusieurs races d'oiseaux participe à
l'information du doigt nos les picaros
qui vivent sur les rochers les plus
aptes et surtout les douanes ice se son
espèce de corberon qui se rassemblent on
y mange troupeau
mais moi
nous
l'extraction du guano n'est plus un
travail artisanal
se retrouveront c'est une véritable
industrie qui emploie près de 8000
hommes répartis sur une quarantaine
ville et qui produit chaque année 500
mille tonnes d'engrais
d'extraction était autrefois assurée par
des esclaves aujourd'hui c'est le
travail manuel le mieux payé du pérou
les ouvriers doivent demeurer huit mois
dans les îles sans revenir à terre c'est
une extrêmement rude épreuve
particulièrement je crois pour les
péruviens qui se passe assez mal du
contact de leurs semblables
on trouve sur les îles du guano des
représentants de toutes les races qui
peuplent le pays les indiens des blancs
des noirs des jaunes
oui le travail
d'extraction maintenant et h mais vous
assistez à la mise en
éveil à les voir combien il est facile
de juger de l'importance de la
production en changeant qu'il y a plus
de 40 il productrice de cueno
et voici maintenant les producteurs les
oiseaux légaux anaïs ne sont pas très
sauvage mais il est impossible de les
approcher à plus de 8 ou 10 mètres et
vous allez voir une chose amusante quand
on s'approche du troupeau se dérobe il
s'écarte ils se reforment derrière la
personne qui s'en approche et ça dans un
très très grand certes regardez bien
cela va se produire dans quelques
incidents
pendant
voilà
oui comment ils s'y prennent
sur les mouvements de foule assez
amusant est assez extraordinaire
ou non pas très peur
ces cartes par principe
ces documents à ses clubs
oui ce sont des oiseaux que des oiseaux
les longues marches les oiseaux on
marche
et jusqu'à 9 heures du matin il est
pratiquement impossible de faire son
volet ces oiseaux mai à 9 heures
précises
obéissant à une mystérieuse lois de la
nature on s'élance sur un plan incliné
et prennent l'air ça aussi vous allez le
voir
mais ils sont si nombreux plus de 40
millions dans les différentes dit qu'il
faudra plus de deux heures avant que
toute la troupe les réussi à s'envoler
pour la pêche aux anchois qui constitue
leur nourriture voilà l'envol ils
attendent comme les avions sur un
terrain d'aviation ils attendent
simplement d'avoir la piste à l'heure
une ford et anchois une consommation
fantastique si l'on change que pour
produire une tonne de guano il faut que
les oiseaux a mal quelque 30 tonnes dans
le choix comme il produit chaque année
près de 500 mille tonnes de guano il
avale dont quelques 15 millions de
tonnes d'anchois
weaver
et l'agriculture péruvienne absorbe à
elle seule la presque totalité de la
production du guano car c'est grâce à
cet engrais sans rival que prospèrent
les riches d'oasis de la région côtière
les sacs sont évacués grâce vous allez
le voir à de curieux petit téléphérique
qui permettent de charger des péniches
ils sont ensuite remorqué vers les ports
du pérou mais ce système n'est possible
que parce que les jours de cette partie
du pacifique sont extrêmement calme au
porte véritablement leur nom pour un
fois
et c'est rare
à
dès que l'on toutes les régions que
tient que l'on connaître deux trois ou
quatre cents kilomètres à l'intérieur du
pays on découvre un tout autre monde
l'altiplano ces pays des grands plateaux
des longues collines à environ 4000
mètres d'altitude et s'étend sur une
superficie
plus vaste que celle de la france là
dans le fond d'un vallon perdu existe
une ferme extraordinaire ou quatre
générations de péruviens à force de
travail et de patience ont réussi à
faire pousser des arbres à plus de 4300
mètres ce qui tout de même est un record
avec la même patience des hommes ont
réussi à renouveler l'exploit des
indiens de la préhistoire ils ont
domestiqué un animal très sauvage la
vigogne
ils l'ont fait surtout parce que sa
toison est vraiment une toison d'or
c'est une laine si fine si douce si les
jeunes que les américains là payent
jusqu'à lui dollars la libre mais voilà
voilà quelques jours voilà une vie gagne
produit une livre de laine par an c'est
pourquoi ils l'ont croisé avec son
cousin l'alpaga
ainsi ils ont obtenu un animal hybride
dont la laine à peine moins belle que
celle de la vigogne et trois fois plus
abondante ce kit ou même est plus
rentable
cette ferme est l'une des deux seules du
pays où l'on ait réussi à domestiquer
les vigognes
lorsque ces animaux sont à l'état
sauvage sont très farouche dit très
rapide à la course